I’m sure you’re well-familiar with the
whole pi vs. tau debate.
Many people say that the fundamental circle
constant we hold up should be the ratio of
a circle’s circumference to its radius,
around 6.28, not the ratio to its diameter,
the more familiar 3.14.
These days we call this larger constant “tau”,
popularized by Michael Hartl’s “Tau manifesto”,
although personally, I’m quite partial to
Robert Palais’ proposed notation of a pi
with three legs.
In this manifesto and many other places on
the internet, you can read to no end about
how many formulas look at lot cleaner using
tau, largely because the number of radians
describing a given fraction of a circle is
actually that fraction of tau.
That dead horse is beat, I’m not here to
make the case further.
Instead I’d like to talk about the seminal
moment in history when pi as we know it became
the standard.
For this, one fruitful place to look is at
the old notes and letters by one of history’s
most influential mathematicians, Leonhard
Euler.
Luckily, we now have an official 3blue1brown
Switzerland correspondent Ben Hambrecht who
was able to go to the library in Euler’s
hometown and get his hands on some of these
original documents.
It might surprise you see Euler write (in
French), “Let pi be the circumference of
a circle whose radius = 1”.
That is, the 6.28 constant which we call tau
today, where he was likely using pi as the
greek letter “p” for “perimeter”.
So was it the case that Euler was more notationally
enlightened than the rest of the world?
Fighting the good fight for 6.28?
If so, who’s the villain of our story pushing
the 3.14 constant that students are shown
today?
The work that really established 3.14... as
the commonly recognized circle constant was
an early calculus book from 1748.
At the start of chapter 8, in describing the
semi-circumference of a circle with radius
1, and after expanding out 128 digits of the
this number, the author writes “which for
the sake of brevity I may write π”.
There were other texts and letters here and
there with varying conventions for the notation
of various circle constants, but this book,
and this section in particular, was really
the one to spread the notation through Europe,
and eventually the world.
So who wrote this text with such an unprincipled
take towards circle constants?
Well...Euler again.
In fact, we can also find instances of Euler
using the symbol pi to represent a quarter
turn of a circle, what we would today call
“pi/2”.
In fact, Euler’s use of the letter pi seems
to be much more analogous to our use of the
greek letter theta.
It’s typical for us to let it represent
an angle, but no particular angle.
Sometimes it’s 30o, other times 135o, most
times just a variable for a general statement.
It depends on the problem and context before
us.
Likewise, Euler just let pi represent whatever
circle constant best suited the problem before
him.
Though it’s worth pointing out he typically
framed things in terms of unit circles, with
radius 1, so the 3.14 constant would have
been thought of as the ratio of a circle’s
semi-circumference to its radius, none of
this circumference to its diameter nonsense.
And I think Euler’s use of this symbol carries
with it a general lesson about how we should
approach to math.
What you have to understand about Euler is
that he solved problems.
A lot of problems.
I mean, day in day out breakfast lunch and
dinner this man was thinking about puzzles,
formulas, having insights and creating entire
new fields left and right.
He wrote over 500 books and papers during
his lifetime, what amounted to about 800 pages
per year, with another 400 publications appearing
posthumously.
It’s often joked that formulas in math have
to be named after the second person to prove
them, since the first person will always be
Euler.
His mind was not focused which circle constant
should be taken as fundamental; it was how
do I solve the task sitting in front of him
and writing a letter to the Bernoulli's boasting
about doing so.
For some problems, the quarter-circle-constant
was most natural to think about.
For others, the full circle, and for others
still, the half circle.
Too often in math education the focus is on
which of multiple competing views of a topic
is “right”.
Is it correct to say the sum of all positive
integers -1/12, or is it correct to say it
diverges to infinity?
Can the infinitesimals values of calculus
be taken literally, or is it only correct
to speak in terms of limits?
Are you allowed to divide a number by 0?
These questions in isolation just don’t
matter.
Our focus should be on specific problems and
puzzles, both those of practical application
and those of idle pondering for knowledge’s
own sake.
When questions of standards arise, then, you
can answer them with respect to a given context.
Inevitably, different contexts will lend themselves
to different answers of what seems most natural,
but that’s okay.
Outputting 800 pages a year of transformative
insights seems to be more correlated with
a flexibility towards conventions than it
does with focusing on which standards are
objectively right.
So on this pi day, the next time someone tells
you we should really be celebrating math on
June 28th, see how quickly you can change
the topic to one where you’re talking about
an actual piece of math.